tras el hundimiento del barco que
transportaba decenas de migrantes frente
a las costas de Siria las historias de
familiares de las víctimas mortales
emergen
era el tío de mustafa un inmigrante
libanés que estaba en la embarcación
junto con sus hijos listo
de vacaciones el partido para cumplir
sus sueños no soñaba con obtener otra
nacionalidad
solo anhelaba con inscribir a sus hijos
en una escuela y poderlos alimentar nada
más el barco que zarpó el 20 de
septiembre el distrito de minigun Líbano
transportaba migrantes de distintas
nacionalidades pero en su mayoría
alibaneses sirios y palestinos que
querían llegar a Europa chipre y las
costas italianas los destinos más
solicitados
la tragedia enluta a toda la zona
geográfica de Levante como a este
campamento de refugiados palestinos en
el norte de Líbano bacharnazar tiene un
familiar desaparecido le reclama el
organismo especial de Naciones Unidas
para los refugiados pale por la tragedia
migratoria en el Mediterráneo
nosotros como palestinos tenemos a la
agencia de Naciones Unidas para los
refugiados palestinos su trabajo era
crear empleos y ayudar al pueblo para el
destino hemos perdido a 30 personas en
el barrio
la agencia de Naciones Unidas para los
refugiados palestinos es el único
responsable de este asunto y los líderes
palestinos también deben asumir su
responsabilidad con respecto a llamar
según la ONU más de 5 millones de
palestinos viven actualmente en
campamentos de refugiados se han visto
obligados a abandonar sus hogares debido
a bombardeos israelíes indiscriminados
en la franja de gaza así como la
ocupación de cada vez más territorios
ensis Jordania
una gran parte de los palestinos se
refugian en el Líbano que vive una grave
crisis económica que también ha
impulsado a sus ciudadanos a abandonar
su país